hello a reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch the e3
2016 gameplay demo for a video game that
is coming out in about a week from the
day we are shooting this may be tomorrow
depending on when this is uploaded or
maybe in two months because now I'm
hearing they pushed this game back it's
called days gone a survival horror video
game did not see the trailer for this I
remember like a couple years ago at
least people did request for us to check
this out never did I never seen this on
my own time but one of our topper war
tears out our patreon is whatever video
you request and it's definitely do put
up on the youtubes got a few
discussion-based ones coming soon but
this one is a reaction from though hit
banerjee hey buddy let's get to this he
loves requesting the game ones and we
love what you request only on
PlayStation perfect
yeah scans for you
I can already tell I'm gonna love this
game yeah this is this is the he said
they're usually like this after that's
called something Unreal Engine or some
[ __ ] something unreal for yeah but now
this looks like the last of us Red Dead
this is my kind of game yeah I love this
guy's like muttering dude these are my
kind of adventure games
I just listened definitely makes picking
up a dead guy is a more unsettling cool
huh I wonder if all even think to try to
use that when I play this game we check
the car they communicate to each other
like a limp
well-hit square
good square dammit
that's beautiful
deccan will imagine how much more
beautiful it's gonna look to help ya
after after improving it the past couple
it comes in
whoa whoa no no what gives dude
[Applause]
[Applause]
that was all that [ __ ] with him yeah
well I need to tackle you off the roof
after all looking for it looks like that
[ __ ]
both others only a few red tops like
there's a lot more that oh that's a nice
oh my god run dude you're not gonna win
this one
what are you stopping just go just go
[Music]
yeah
oh nice
yeah that's always satisfying getting
here bike drum with gas or Sun let it
off let it off yeah damn dude you know
wonder you're surviving the apocalypse
mark yeah I'm just gonna keep on in
circles keeper in service where's your
motorcycle doc nice good car they call
you let that [ __ ] up fast it how you
scare that's a very deep little bag yes
every time he stops the shooter just
like stop why so fairly you don't have
to just do headshots for these pretty
tours or do they call it
creepers
oh my god that guy's right next to you
how about that guys you didn't get you
how did he know to go to a big dining
look the game developers getting scared
playing when they're all too afraid to
play it that's when I say the game we
can release this man it's like oh yeah
oh oh here it gonna be sword ha ha
I don't know that break in through there
why are you drawing attention to
yourself where's your motorcycle GTFO
we're not screaming his head off he's
used to this he's getting a workout
that's what he's doing right now does he
expect to just kill all these people
does he haven't always the red dots mean
like you got to take care of that
specific swarm on
yeah there must be like a certain swarm
of that that you have to take down
shoot the drum
Hey
that'll stop they won't be able to I
mean there's so many it's like it World
War Z oh my god oh there's so many of
them
my god alright I are surviving this oh
yeah [ __ ] you get that way casually take
my time putting this in here yeah just
move very slow can't be hasty with
organization nice I'm a wiry the assault
rifle that just seems like the most
efficient way to kill oh man 20
like this guy's tattoos
oh that one a reactor should why are you
here - just keep running
have you not like falling off this will
just keep running don't shoot
Oh
you ran to the worst possible spot yeah
you are completely surrounded there's no
way you could get more bullets no way
you're still shouting come on after that
guy you were looking for it turned out
to be such a bust like get on your blade
why was he looking for ever need use
after all that man fascinating teaser
because I'm so dazzled by like just what
is physically happening but I'm a little
confused by the actual I confused by the
logic of why are you still here run to
your bike why did you do so much for
this guy who at no point at least in
this interaction had any intention of
helping you going along with you or
being part of your plan I'm really happy
if that large quantity it's terrifying
when you turn around they're all come so
close to you and the the difficulty I
have with games would where you have to
shoot creatures like this is usually
it's like headshots or it takes a lot
more bullets to take them down or
something some more specific which is
kind of terrifying I like here that with
the quantity of rounds you can unload
you don't have to like only headshot
that hard to kill it's just that there's
an obscene amount point where it's just
like I got imagine this would be a very
scary game to actually play because I
was freaking out not only do you have
all that intensity of the horde itself
but you also had those little moments
like when he's investigating that little
trunk at one point and then one of them
just comes out of nowhere right behind
you like that jump-scare thing which
like a flashback to Resident Evil like I
think everybody has that you know pants
crapping Lee horrifying memory of like
when you're going down that one hall in
the first game and the dog jumps through
the window
you lose your [ __ ] like you mind me of
that I'm looking forward I want to see
more of of it you know because of course
with a I think this was their first
gameplay they did I wonder they there
must be another law because this is from
2016 so there has to be another game
play out for this nope just the one one
and then people just hope that one
releases from three months ago that's an
80 minute gameplay demo Wow okay alright
let's react to that good those seem like
there are a lot like a lot of them like
yeah you know games take like 20 hours
to game like this is like if you don't
bother with any of the sides well I
wonder how much I don't know if this is
open-world I mean at least from what I
read up on it doesn't sound like it's
open-world seems like that it's a very
specific adventure you have to go down
yeah on the whole time I hope it's not
only that the whole time because I do
like the whole figuring out and for
games like this you do need a compelling
storyline to keep you again I mean the
world sounds really cool to me because I
heard that it's more than just like the
zombie humans that you doing it like
bears and wolves in here who are also
they call them freaker's yeah yeah and I
feel like free games like this
especially with that you know we
slightly changed some things it's
essentially a zombie game for something
like this you do need a very compelling
storyline like for me Last of Us is one
of my favorite video games and it's
because a story lino they're so cool
this is like my kind of male action here
I like to get on board with I like how
in video games now with the situations
like this they do have the characters
react in circumstances that's why I was
kind of thrown back I'm like why is he
not like freaking out about any of these
yeah and then every once a while he's
just like whoa [ __ ] dammit
has a reaction like that that makes it
that much more gripping like oh yeah
yeah well that's a little thing about
modern games that I do really appreciate
is just like the little aside lines
where they're talking to themselves or
whatever it is at all maybe I could use
this yeah and he looks like Sam Witwer
because I believe Sam Witwer like is
this character at least yeah I did the
voice and I wonder if maybe mocap
because it does look a lot like him oh
no it absolutely does Sam Witwer from
the movie trivia show daddy's right I
know that
and Steven editing is the Miss yes and
voicing for one of the Star Wars
animated shows - yeah yeah that's Sam
Witwer gets around man yeah it does look
like him and I like about the
personality in the costume design of
this guy is I don't know what city this
takes place in or state that it's
inspired Colorado Springs comma one
could only hope but it he does just look
like you know ripped a vest on a t-shirt
like a dude and he probably had some
type of lifestyle beforehand where he
would go hunting or my motorcycle you
know just like a dude all of the above
yeah this looks like a really cool game
it's cool that it's cool that might
really I think it was pushed back to
April as according to acuity here yeah
it says they delayed it to allow for
them to polish so yeah for years we
swear we'll be done no more okay and
then they'll hit thanks for requesting
this buddy and we were looking up your
name and on Google it says that your
name literally means offer which is this
guy's name oh just like you guys are
named after each other it's like I'm
petting you right now do you have
cat-like tendencies like if we met would
you like nuzzle up on me right away it's
like I'm looking you
I know I'll do that's how cats give each
other about hygiene is everything that's
how my girlfriend and I give each other
baths
I mean saves a lot of one when I go to
Canada to visit you that's how I'm
giving you a bath
I'm just gonna lick you up and down
everywhere I once had a transgender
person tell me that and they follow
through with that order oh well done
hey man I'm gonna I'm looking forward to
this experimenta Canada and I've also
never filmed a tongue bath so I think
I'm gonna come along and document this
experience I believe we did already do a
shout out for low head where I did this
exact joke do you really
comment below low head and tell me if
I've already repeated myself sometimes
repeating the joke is just it's like a
sequel to a comedy movie well the thing
is like cats on the internet doesn't
matter how many times you repeat the
joke like people just love that shiz
yeah we're gonna use one of these
moments it's the thumbnail cat reacts is
not fighting it stop fighting and
conquer yourself I just want to know
what you think in this moment guys you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and we'll catch
you soon yay